it meant everything to us like you get
in the belts and then you hey everybody
welcome to another episode of hot box
and I'm Evan Britton and I'm Mike Tyson
Mike we've got a crew are today the
wrong [ __ ] going down with just a legend
Noriega in the house oh man I'm so happy
one love but forget again three in the
morning I get it no I get up at 2:00 in
the morning I go downstairs I listened
to some Ella Fitzgerald smoked up some
it didn't throw him I go into around
three o'clock I going to my bike I went
to the bike for hours and I come stood
and I walk through the treatment for our
and but when I do the treadmill the bike
I had my headphones up when I go
upstairs
I just the treadmill and they said my
toes in the pool and I put the one loved
one that's why I start walking through
fire remix remix one love thank you game
for having me a part of the one love
real estate man that's great Ricky yo
but Mike man let me tell you something
man I watched a podcast but yeah thank
you but yours too I'm a big fan of it
and you're fluent something like smoking
that way I started smoking I wanted
[Applause]
so you're always feeling good-looking
night are my I thought people want to
see if that our better so let's let's
get straight into it go for it in my
podcast there's a famous story right
with the locks the locks was walking
through on a red carpet and they said
that you walk through by yourself
probably yeah and you [ __ ] you tonight
there's not any time this is not me -
yes for you free me to go with the
lockers I thought she could drain was
did to dr. Dre yeah I was just living my
life back then oh my god befriend the
close friends them go straight oh yeah
I'ma be honest I sinned man imma be I'm
taking over
no it's all good but I'll be honest man
do you even know what you meant for New
York City man huh like like yo when we
went out of town yeah when we went out
of town for New York City I'm just
because I've seen Jim Jones on here and
I seen when he said when you walk
through the tunnel by the way which is
the most horrific club ever at this time
and we're Michael walk through Michael
walk through by itself just I'm a
cosigner with Jim Jones said jury on and
everyone just move on but I mean get to
the point the point I'm trying to say is
do you understand like New York City
like it was it was the proudest we've
ever been man let me tell you something
okay listen I can remember being 1 1976
bad guy human being on 42nd Street
snatching people's change me snatch that
Wireless rip their pockets out I'll
snatch something off the stand they some
clothes or something and I was just a
regularly all my a year of the regularly
so and every now and then some of those
Spanish guys are just see me an ace must
have saw me rob some
their customers the week before and they
may start throwing stuff you
[ __ ]
and such don't get that [ __ ] watch
that mother for either TV starts talking
loud mm on top of his voice and the
whole neighbors this Stephen
[ __ ] watch that little black
bastard you know and it comes from
listen I come ten years old it's 1986
now those same people that they're
giving me free Tufts taking pictures
with me now same stuff to try to kick me
in my ass and I used to come by nowadays
make pitches kissing on me and
everything taking pictures with their
babies now what do you stand with Don
King what happened Don listen I'm cool
with Don King are you passionate about
what's your smoking dirty box and not
listen in a way like you were smoking no
I used to smoke doing my amateur days
right and then um I didn't make it to
the Olympic truck so I [ __ ] got
massive offense because of this weed
that's why I didn't make it to the
Olympic so I stopped smoking weed from
like 84 mmm
to [ __ ] like 97 yeah I wanted to be
champion mmm Wanda mean in my life yeah
you know yeah I wanted my mother to be
proud she had died I wanted them to be
proud of me Oh someone to be Jim you
know that at that age you don't know you
think being coming rich and famous it's
the essence of life because that's what
TV makes you believe when you're a young
kid but you know they just come it
compounds your problems
yeah hey but like hey but no Mike
selling it maybe I know my team ready to
blow up what do you thinks gonna happen
now this depends on me how I handle the
situation
I don't pass the test the first time at
a lot of money but this time is going to
be different
I'm sorry well you know we need y'all on
drink chance right definitely late you
want to start this start this what you
do what ahh like you know party says yes
podcast yet nothing will do Candida I
don't like hearing my [ __ ] voice and
[ __ ] so I did so we did the podcast one
day and then the [ __ ] can I get some the
ratings went off the roof and so I what
is what are we doing what's you
surprised of course you knew the radius
was gonna go up to me yeah let me ask
you you were not surprised
well then I'm surprised because I know
oh yeah I mean I think you know Mike
Mike is a guy who I've learned he really
just goes where the universe takes him
you know and really learns a lot as he
goes and he was really into podcasts I
mean podcasts for the wave of the future
is a six on it man business as far as
communication and entertainment it goes
you know I came here broken with a habit
[Music]
yeah yeah when you say junky what you
mean junkie like cocaine okay okay
what's really cool is that this podcast
from start to finish
well we're not done yet but you know
it's really been a watching Mike on his
journey to self and prestige 101 man
what made you do the one man stand I'm
sorry I'm taking over cuz you know what
when I heard of it I didn't see it but
when I saw it I was like this is genius
yeah I thought um chad commentary the
guy that did um was thinking wrong still
a Bronx Tale so he did it on stage
instead he did it on stage and I told my
wife baby I couldn't do that hmm I said
it's like me Europe but Europe you
attacking me question I won't let him
actually question I do like mr.
Parmenter ego from an actor point of
view
yeah Eddie Mike is amazing you know I
would have never thought that no [ __ ]
me up right now got my credit card who
got the wine cuz we're going in let me
just tell you something man
I watch up I watch our podcast I watch
you all which you guys do and I want to
congratulate you guys to your face
because Vegas the thing is no one could
do what y'all do and how y'all doing
I love it like I sincerely love it I sit
back and I watch it and I really love
what you guys are doing so I want to say
it to your face I didn't say no because
I said it on Twitter and I set it on
Instagram before but you know um you
know we're gonna take our coaching this
is what's happening in the world we're
gonna take our culture and this is the
first step because every time a boxer
should announce a fight they should be
here yeah yeah I was talking to UM
that's what we should do we should
promote people fighting like llama
chenko and David yes one more take off
should be here yes yeah how you feel
about least the [ __ ] best
you think you yeah because he is having
low losses right now no but listen he
only has 9 5 12 fights under 20 no but
he got 500 amateur fights ok this is
amateur mean that much yeah no what no
what means a lot okay I'm repetition the
way you do it the more you do it
you see when he fight he's almost doing
it with his eyes closed you see no one
no one ever gave him no one ever won
around only one guy wondering I think
this guy dropped and he's only got
everyone around but he guys he came up
and knocked the guy out cold with a body
punch but I don't think I'd ever be one
around cuz he dropped them but other
than that he's he's never lost a round
beside that one fight smoke Brownville
blunts yeah take one here take one here
cuz you gotta say you gotta take a brown
girl
let me tell you something
I used to bribe [ __ ] in Brownsville
with my brows real cousins it was
horrible you know you know it's crazy my
brows because it's March Madness cousins
by the way um I went and we robbed the
[ __ ] in the barbershop it's horrible
it's horrible because the guy was
getting the shape-up came to get me the
Bobby shot one day no I'm sorry my man
bothers but I'm in there with this
crackhead came in it I said listen it
might be here cuz okay I bought your
haircut if you let me [ __ ] are you Mike
Mike yeah Mike will you buy me a yeah
I'll buy you a haircut but you gotta let
me cut it and so I'm trying to cut his
hair I learn and the barber to only sell
my messing on my you guys do like he
grabbed me there but the like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] came in then a guy
grabbed the gun and pushed him back and
he kicked the gun and put me a boo-boo
me that's got bubble blowing the [ __ ]
to close it up what's that [ __ ] but
then again right the [ __ ] that
was in there what stick-up kids I think
he was coming to get dumb oh I said
we'll stick up kid is coming to get this
stick of a kid yeah that's all listen do
you know my man screw from Jersey City
yes I know I've definitely was not there
yeah that was Capone yeah no I was not
there we took a loss yeah damn that was
definitely that was definitely a bit up
the school let them and bigger to Brock
royal because they all you know I'm
Latino so they always come see me and
they get us get me confused but that was
definitely components definitely okay
what are you smoking a blunt
no but but might let me let me ask you a
question this is a president because I
just go to Branson a lot yeah and I
found the time of Branson this there was
a altercation that happened with you and
Mitch green daddy yeah yeah you know
Mitch green just a drunk junkie [ __ ] is
coming at talking sh I like him it's but
he was just being disrespectful
oh yes had to get he for Brooklyn - nah
he's in Queens oh no what'd you do Mitch
would do this Mitchell um he was outside
I feel like himself did you do this
he'll go to the gas station right and
forgive me the [ __ ] money H I robbed
a gas station attendant so the gas
station is how you start out I got no
money so it meant you a time up and
[ __ ] stop pumping gas that's insane
so what happens - y'all got there cuz
that began this around 4:00 in the
morning uh-huh
I came back from DC Rose knows um you
know gonna add the college time in
Howard you have a hole come along yes I
came back and pick up my clothes from
dapper Africans always been at work at
night and sometimes there's some hot
chicks in there and for the morning yeah
big time you'd be surprised
and so I went this way buddy and then
I'm talking everybody laughing Walter
Perry was there too and right and I was
laughing right and next time when he
killed everybody stop lever forgiveness
scared to death and for the record how
tall are you 510
okay till half but listen you're
installing me up that's where [ __ ]
you ain't beat me after what
[ __ ] I was gonna give him some
money came in for some money I was gonna
give him a G I was looking my G but he
said some Far East are talking some
gangster [ __ ] like Keith this sensation
is said yes you said it so yeah yeah
well you so happen
[Laughter]
you know what I get to hit a story yeah
first I read it in the papers and I was
like oh well last night we is this
hotbox I'm live and somebody said did
you know Mitch green as a preacher now
get the [ __ ] outta preach it I don't
believe in [ __ ] that's what somebody
said and they said Mike if that's true
you guys want his church go mr. Hale
yeah wait while I'm looking this up what
you get in the hut in the podcast yeah
best [ __ ] vodka you had the [ __ ]
real live homeboy yeah killer drinking
[ __ ] well thank you thank you but what
happened was I watched what is it TNT
Charles Barkley and Jack in these guys
and I said although I disagree with
their opinion I can see that these guys
come from the culture they come from the
game so I said where's our [ __ ]
you know I'm saying like like in my
opinion I think every boxer in the world
from Earl Spence to Floyd Mayweather
should be sitting here in my opinion if
they don't smoke that's okay that's cool
too that's kinda like what but the thing
about it is there's no one in the
universe that can't say we don't know
Mike
no no let me out let me out cuz I know
you humble i watch them I watch this
[ __ ] I know you but let me let me big
you up for you okay I'll take that but
um Earl Spence and I forget who he just
fought Porter Laura Earl Spencer
important should have been here they
shouldn't be promoting in here as
opposed to ESPN and TNT and that's good
it's good because that's the people
that's paying the check but at the end
of the day
when you have your own support in your
own they should come to you and that's
that I would rather I would rather watch
the next fight
whether it's Manny Pacquiao verse Danny
Garcia I rather watch that being
promoted on here I respect that listen
that's awesome to know what I would love
to have them on but the line is too
[ __ ] long no III want to stop you the
line is not long when it comes to Mike
Tyson oh my bad my bad my bad
oh look dude there's a video credit card
tubas diminish green has turned
Christian Mike can we film this and I
will go to the church with you I will go
to the church with you me you they got
him on a pope right now is he talking
what is he thinking I wish I I don't
think we have our setup president
standing in the foyer and reading that
passage and wondering if that could
really be true if I could be an unlikely
editor after all that I've been through
out to all that I had done after all the
guilt and shame that I had left in my
past could I really be new and I was
told constantly you don't have to be a
drug addict anymore you don't have to be
an alcoholic anymore not if you don't
want to be you can be new I don't have
to go back to my old life I know that
now
beautiful Jesus drink some wine yeah
hell yeah dude
but do you really know how much you mean
in New York City like I would be so
proud to walk through any neighborhood
now you know what I'm be honest with you
that might have been the realest [ __ ] I
ever heard because that's exactly what
New York is like they tell you a billion
now is that what that's all you got
that's all I'm not full yet I didn't
ever even touch the tip of the [ __ ]
beak me take something I'll tell you one
I'll tell you one thing like I was in
Miami for like a year and a half and I
came back to New York
violet and my [ __ ] was looking at me
like why you smiling they don't want
like you're smiling a new you said that
before too but listen man every time I
go to Miami I have a habit of a venereal
disease
you know how to talk to me they know how
to make a [ __ ] out the energy there is
really seductive isn't it you know
I know nothing I'm bumping with this
book was another their [ __ ] calumny
Alcala me why you [ __ ] I'm just [ __ ]
the life is crazy
yeah I with the Cuba because you've been
the Cuban don't my wife trying to give
me to go to Cuba but I've never been
it's easy to get there now I wonder who
you couldn't go to buy what they keep
[ __ ] cuz Trump let [ __ ] go to Cuba
right yeah but I went there we wasn't
cool the goal is I want the Cure to go
to to make I wanted to make sure to go
to keep one of those it means to Dell
did you know understand what do you say
he went to Cuba to go to Jamaica I guess
when you went there and the guy saw me I
miss walking since my summer hey Mike
thanks what are you doing here why are
you walking here and he said you need a
woman I said that could be cool so the
guy goes I'm in this house so I'm gonna
tell he goes in the backyard go down a
street and this is a [ __ ] a little
creepy back yeah it's really creepy
though huh they're gonna killed me back
there right uh-huh
creepy and the [ __ ] beautiful girl
comes out of this junkie [ __ ] house a
beautiful [ __ ] [ __ ] decrepit and
everything they're poor and this
beautiful woman comes out the house he
says a woman but when I left it right I
was just like you dookied out get
diamonds and everything
I'm [ __ ] they're so poor I had to give
her all my [ __ ] I had to take this you
feel so sorry for this oh oh oh [ __ ] are
these we're billionaire oh I was never
there yeah I was never day I'll give a
couple of hundred dollars that's party
everything let me tell you something how
was your life because you know what you
can either bring these you Brooklyn yeah
you broke the boy
partiece all these stories and I could
you know I watch you guys sure but I'm
amazed every single time are you amazed
sitting here witness do this every
single time oh do you know every story I
know a lot of the story sorry Mike and I
have gotten to know each other really
well how did this come together I'm
taking although sorry no no it's all
good old foot I appreciate that
how did this come together so I came in
to help Mike put on this medical
cannabis summit to talk about how
cannabis can be a powerful medicine for
athletes because I played in the NFL and
cannabis is really the one thing that
can help guy's brains heal from
concussions let me stop you right there
well you smoke weed during fights only
once okay only once what fight was that
Andrew Golota one of his best fights
ever okay definitely don't remember that
one I'm like the first time I met Mike
he gave me a hug and I was like just
struck by his humility and his humanity
and his love in his heart
it was beating in me and I didn't
surrender easy well you know man it
brought me and that made me love you and
I just wanted to do everything I could
to help fast forward a couple years
later they're saying we want to start
this podcast and you know it all just
came together hotboxing though because
mike and then you added a cannabis
element and here we are because what
made you want to do that that's that's
the big part biggest question
I'm telling you [ __ ] the truth you
don't want to do the to be talking
[ __ ] that's what I thought other
guys too good I have when I was losing
interest in it that's all yeah that is
fun right we got smoked weed during it
thank you
Mike thank you Mike thank you that is
fun yes fun and you know we would love
to have y'all on the podcast well I
don't drink but death yes you know you
know what my and it was us it was us are
Peter our energy I'm entirely are we all
know this the person you know that
person 100 years ago that's who we are
this is our generation it's genetics
that's what we did we're on the corner
talking [ __ ] hanging out getting high
yeah that's a lost art did you never see
that no more I just wanna throw this out
there I just want to throw this out
there Mike there's no one who will not
answer your phone call I want to throw
this out there
let's just be cursor random name out a
storm round let's play game thinking
this is nori games on all right random
name out there yeah and I want to see
everyone say yes or no if they answer
miss Tyson's Corner all right yeah we're
gonna stalk y'all ready yeah give me a
like somebody okay so this is Mike Tyson
calling a random person is everybody
ready yeah yeah Madonna Madonna picking
up good people yes okay okay sorry never
ever too
number two good what do what's my man
named Bernie Sanders burning so yea
burning my pigs really liberal he back
out there I'll still vote for Bernie
number three we honor and I would have
met somebody that damn hard I never met
her like like but but I'll never man
so Mike she's we got on the pot I wish I
was young girl smokers I'm not gonna lie
your eyes turn different when I said we
are I would love for my daughter to meet
her that would be awesome
that's when you know your real [ __ ]
yeah when you say I love for my kids
yeah that's some real [ __ ] right there
so you never met Rihanna nah listen to
me slamming say something man
you make us so proud because anytime but
you know I look at anything I could say
this is the New York City and me okay
but no one was you talk about those
broads right
when it comes to women and I think about
my history with women and to this moment
right now
um a great deal of my time was wasted on
that that was a waste
it was illusions was my mind playing
tricks and pictures on me I see you say
on one time or you have all their belts
in front of you you think it means look
lovely tune what did you mean by that
like because you actually it meant
everything to us
like
you get in the belts and then you must
have reached the biggest accolade well
that's my illusion my illusion is always
bigger than me anybody know it's [ __ ]
Gandhi he's the new version of Gandhi
the boy no no can I ask you something
what's that
would like to hear what matters most to
you now what means something to you wow
this I don't know I don't know how to
answer that what do I answer that from
my ether yet that opens me up for my ego
to get involved no ego is off my like my
kids that live a healthy respectable
life what's the ego so know the world
[ __ ] yeah so now as a fan as a man this
is pure as a fan and and as a recent fan
we seem to whack 100 footage we couldn't
tell if that was real fake you couldn't
tell this all love whack of beautiful
people yeah but pop was your brother
yeah cuz they came to see you in jail I
had a picture of that yeah I thought
Park came to visit me in prison
Wow in Indiana yeah he was so crazy that
day actually why this guy's not that's
it well first met him he's beautiful
course this guy's crazy
who took my pot yeah today you can't
never see you yeah I bet biggie I met um
possibly this is energy fire so so in
retrospect just just just to clarify it
let's just say let's just say let's say
whatever happened but in retrospect
when whack was saying whatever he was
saying was you
the finding park oh oh oh this was just
having them in the interview okay let's
get hot come on man wait let's my man
big one yeah yeah that was so funny cuz
I was like and this happened at El
Segundo seven right over there in our
old kitchen over there you know the
kitchen over there how'd you build a
weed resort oh yeah you ever we dynasty
okay I need Empire going on it's a
resort
yeah check in you get bought weed that's
what it's made for that's the only
purpose is originated you could buy but
if you like Palm Springs Desert Hot
Springs area yeah right off the toe
before you fit the cello beautiful
nobody say that there are nobody's ever
seen anything that's been the first of
its kind it's been the first of its
invention and I would be delighted to
give you a room for free I wanted to be
some like 7000 ight [ __ ] Hotel what I
want welcome man no boo to come and cook
you sort of sashimi absolutely trying to
tell you that Japanese town with and
tell me afro town what was what was the
most starstruck moment where a person
came to see you because like everyone I
read your memoirs I see you
documentaries people come see you in
jail what was the the illest person that
came to see York all reached out to you
that you thought would never work one
prison anyway if anywhere
that llama nice presence of country
presence of Chesney presence of Turkey
president that's crazy that's good so
all life is different than Tom
perspectives different over than in and
the [ __ ] Eastern European Europe
because there let me just break down
lock down what they say it now was
Anthony Wilder was my man named Tod
Wilder they say on tape Wilder is not
identifying or the crowd is not
identifying with him so he can go to
Kentucky and chill you could you
couldn't go to any country you can't go
anywhere
yeah but that's that that's the design
that was the design we think that we
think you think that happens I was most
I was fighting while he look what
happened guys know I was designed for
that to happen
what do you mean so they called the
paparazzi Friday no no I'm from let me
say divine guidance so to speak I was
born to be that guy when I've shown the
seem not to be egotistical everybody was
to see me it's not because of who I am
I'm graded was just designed that way
yet my life means nothing it's just the
way somebody wanted it to be you've been
a career mmm I bet at the airport but
not in the city now okay crazy that's
why we just had this Robin here today we
were talking about he's just left why do
you think a guy like Deontay Wilder
doesn't get recognized by the audience
by the fans well you know what probably
one of the greatest questions I've ever
been asked I think Deontay Wilder
is not acts the crazy question to these
acts the crazy questions like like like
when he says till this day to this day
but the thing is I feel like people
don't want him to be axed a crazy
question because he's dark and you know
big and
big listen you're absolutely right about
that girl uh no big boss he needs to
play the role is to gentlemen mmm you
know see a guy like me I played the role
of the villain because out shorter than
everybody Mulder than everybody so it
doesn't really look like this might be
the little guy so I gotta do that little
guys talking shitty saying this writing
that and it's just a character yeah
that's interesting it's interesting yet
tonight what my situation I'll be honest
with you might you know ultimate villain
hero villain your whole career
you've been the ultimate like villain
hero I'm not my level then I guess em
that's what it is
[Laughter]
yo yeah but let me tell you something I
want to reiterate this as a New York
City kid when we went out of town people
would see us and ever say no New York
who said you will you probably see Tyson
yep Cooper claim that [ __ ] behind you
claim it back let's go to you when you
first got put on in this music and I
mean you and um oh yeah how'd that work
out how did y'all get along well we got
a long phenomenal because we were broke
and it was it was it was awesome I still
speak to poems to this day I wanted him
to come here actually say hey I wanted
to surprise him and come here but he
will always be my friend but forever and
always because the one thing for sure
two things are certain
I never seen Capone hit on me not one
that's not what's great about one minute
not one minute like you know maybe I had
a little bit more accolades I had a
little bit more success but I told that
to my nephew the other day I was like yo
you know what I could never front up on
like whatever palm walk to me or need
for me I will always be there for him
because he never ever ever ever ever
ever show
any hate like that's my brother so
you're from Queens the reason I'm from
Queens for LeFrak City okay so do you um
that that we're not is from nas is from
20 minutes away 15 minutes away
Queensbridge yes as from your bonus from
as well yes come on Mikey wait you try
to get into your journalism [ __ ] I've
been dreaming them from around this
agreement that was [ __ ] 15 minutes the
other with that 40 that's 40 projects
and you know big up to pre pre wanna
call in I mean Prince student beautiful
thing about you Mike is you was New York
City champion but everyone from the
Bronx for me I forget man named Boy
George yeah to miss green every one of
the inner-city gangsters [ __ ] with you
I will listen up let's keep it real I
was um
I stood when I was young somebody to
drop cribs you know it's be exchange
snatch - you said Crips or cribs gonna
be apartments and stuff like I have him
girl got locked up I happen to go
upstate New York they went and did their
place upstate year I want my direction I
got could got involved in boxing they
went back into drugs and crime and we
just went different directions but we
still loved each other we still grew up
with each other so every time when I got
money I came and I took him out when we
were still friends my mother knew their
mother I stayed over their house ate
sugar and water
that kind of stuff so I don't know it
was weird when somebody say hey you can
hang with them that [ __ ] me up then
that time I got my problem started I
know this guy's mother I don't know you
you do that make sense
that's why we could never be racist from
New York yeah mother had diapers then
you could tell me nothing around oh I
can hang on
there's evidence that is the most
beautiful you cannot be racist coming
from New York yeah because I just grew
up around a Haitian or Russia and all in
my home oh you can't be racist come on
yo cuz everybody live you live listen if
they living where you living at they're
doing bad my neighbor he's [ __ ] up you
think about robbing and you know he has
no [ __ ] and if he lived in our
neighbors nobody wants them hot box we
are hot have you guys ever met before
you remember [ __ ] [ __ ] I got this we
really know that Michael every time you
do this
[Laughter]
but anyway I wanna say big up to my boy
scooter Lew Hobbs you know I keep in
touch with them those guys I'll go visit
them all the time as much as I possibly
can my shot I'll shoot the store out
there
yeah Sheila's love pick up my man push
I forgot my mat do so we will my man
Mike both whimper go young really this
is my life journey it's to always
support them and be down with them to
the end of time so so in boxing right
Mike because in boxing I would like to
ask you this question sometimes a person
with just me and rap right when this man
in general and if I diss them back I'm
am I making them all my level because no
matter who you fight on that night are
they on your level that's him
that's up to you that's your discipline
what are you gonna do that's the choice
you have to make I need to hit yeah you
have to make that choice what do you
think don't care what I think I'm what I
think doesn't matter you are [ __ ] what
do you think how does it affect you you
feel like a [ __ ] ago somebody said that
and you didn't come back no oh is it in
your mind you worry about somebody's
gonna say yo man what's up with it you
didn't do it nobody's ever gonna say
that so you ever took a fight and
someone was outside in the crowd and
saying I want to fight Mike and you did
it just offer ego oh well like I'm in
the ring and somebody I want you [ __ ]
back yes I did that so Oliver called
came it you be somebody else up the
Oliver call came all right um he was in
the ring fighting in Chicago that's a
firm and I was there doing some business
so and so I said I'm gonna go to the
fight tonight until he knock this guy
out the ring and he pointed any I want
you and so he was he was he was like I
don't know 20 contender so I said well
he's not gonna make no money fighting me
so I said come to my camp and we
strain on my sparring partner all those
got to be talking I see I'm gonna be
tight uncle I said what we can't frame
that list this train
let me get you prepared for me okay and
I pay them and you spot this this might
be the greatest question of my life
this might be the go for realist
question of gold [ __ ] is they said when
you fought Buster Douglas hmm that he
knocked you down in the training session
or dad no no he didn't like my sparring
partner knocked me down Oh
pride Oh prior to Japan yeah I was in
Japan when he knocked me down and I have
to ask ourselves the ax said that Mike
Tyson was on cocaine and a whole lot of
other cool it wasn't okay are you not
being okay don't do his [ __ ] [ __ ]
though that that was also part of the
room cuz I'm you know I'm a big boxing
fan I don't know I'm the I'm the biggest
might taste afraid I might know more
about your life than you I'm just
stalling it off go with that but you
know you know I want to be honest with
you Tyson talk to me man noria that was
the worst day of my life
mmm that was the best day of mine yeah
you know I jumped up with turnstiles
just to come because I knew you it's
gonna be a 12-second fight so my father
everyone we all gathered around and I
jumped a turnstile and I got caught and
that's when I knew it was a bad day cuz
I never got caught jumping the turnstile
I'm not getting good copy in a [ __ ]
woman come on
music use the greatest and that was like
I was probably the worst thing of my
childhood
yeah but no what's so weird about the
listen um let's take how did you have
you know if I [ __ ] egos a [ __ ]
right so it's Japan
yeah we in Japan but I say to myself
even though I lost right my next fight
still got was thirty or forty million
dollars I never really lost really I
really never lost but I learned a lesson
that you have to prepare you're not
[ __ ] God [ __ ] I learned that what
but I will go fight guys and I will beat
them yourself a termination alone right
and I got comfortable I guess somebody
said [ __ ] I'm a fight back by right that
was what end and was it him that never
wanted the rematch
yeah because cuz he got the money he
just never came back he just he just
left he played himself a lot you know
gaining that weight lost in three rounds
we won the championship is supposed to
keep you pride wants to give you thing
he's supposed to prepare to die for that
but you saw the beating I took when I
lost it he's supposed to be prepared to
take a beating like that yeah you did it
was 13 seconds an all-county cool but
you don't give the title update you take
that B now you die for it
yeah so so so let me ask you
so after this this all all these things
happen and then you go to jail yeah and
then you come home yeah
what make you want to take my boxing
again at that time my ego cuz she was
boxing to jail no someone say I'm coming
come back I'm gonna be bigger than I was
when I went it's my ego cuz I felt shame
and [ __ ] I'm jealous because other
people were making money when I was in
prison
nobody supposed to make money if I'm
honest see nobody's supposed to make
money I dictate if you make money or not
it's like a dope [ __ ] on the corner I
dictate who make money who fights who
and where so what do you think about
these other promoters now like the Luda
Bella's I think they're a lot better
than the promoters in my day and you
know a boxer asked who's not bad you
know
I suppose my bad soon some stuff is
going is having boxing didn't really
change again to my else is gonna take
over boxing like in a few months you'll
probably hear about it it'll be a new
[ __ ] Titan in the game new guy that
kind of thing you know years too but you
know I came into new name not Floyd
no [ __ ] as what I think was insane
fighter really insane there's no doubt
about that that's cool - you do that -
he's good at that you know he's really
young appear that he got this [ __ ]
together you know looking at for me it's
a free point he looks like he's just
lounging let's make some noise
iiiiii I enjoy Floyd and do you do you
ever get mad and when people compare you
to Ally
no I'm so happy when they do that yeah
that's that's tough that's no I would I
would never taught you to say that
because you know you are Liz
and in black people culture y'all really
[ __ ] Ali is his son and see you guys
don't know is just more than you can't
dream that he is oh [ __ ] I ain't that
right how was it when you met him but I
met him when I was in Spofford when I
was like 11 years old let's go yeah we
so we came in here before the movie the
great it's right nothing new battling
with the hip you know hey what's going
on and then I'm after the movie was over
he came in everybody lost it but you're
not Mike Tyson your office mice
treatment I'm a pickpocket [ __ ] right
so um I saw him my whole life changed
that day and then like a month or two
later I got shipped upstate oh [ __ ]
no I'm Jonathan James town upstate by
opening okay y'all and there's some
white guy came in and he says the kids
are know some kids I was in there I was
in the hole cuz I was new and I got [ __ ]
from one dorm to the lockup dorm I'm
fighting the shit's and one guy said
we're boxing or whatever mr. Stewart and
I wanted to get over this and say I
wanted the box - and then I met them and
he taught me how to box
six weeks after meeting Eileen Wow
Mike Tyson but did you met him after you
was Mike yeah how was telling them my
story they forget the [ __ ] I mean I'm
almost crying unless you get his bag
are you busting my child yeah but I knew
that's what I wanted to do that for
sugary limit and 79 5 wolf urban either
then the R and F at this where I want to
do yeah here last week still it's no one
this is throw it out there there's no
one you can't call it's true but I just
want to tell you Mike in case you don't
know there's no one in the universe that
will tell you no no listen this is what
I have this true this when I have to
know it's true you put out energy this
will happen um when you when you feel
that way somebody need to tell you know
who you think will tell you know let's
just throw it out there Bobby Sanders
come I should say no thing about that
way for my shits they [ __ ] you now what
they about I want Ivana I love a sound
enough time for a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it doesn't matter oh yeah so what
country you been to that you be was like
the president came to see us you you had
the bit like you had to be like listen
right I was in Romania right I'm in
Romania and there's a lot of that you
can normally there on the beach there
they have no Carson a kid on the beach
right and so there's these gangster guys
these big [ __ ] steroids [ __ ] these
new European gangsters and they just
falling in a tonight and it's watching
right ten of them and then they see and
they're trying to figure out what is it
that they said to see me talking to the
girl so they bring more girls over but
they don't talk to me right so they see
him break the girls and so then they
sell me they must have saw it
cocaine mmm like that wasn't ready good
then the guy walked away and came back
and he had a [ __ ] big [ __ ] bag of
cocaine put it right in front of me
hasn't said a word do you never said a
word to me just watching my they do this
again so I like the girls he made more
girls come over never said a word he saw
me sniff a little cocaine tried to sneak
some cocaine never thought it came back
and brought a big [ __ ] powder cocaine
right here running like this never said
a word to me crazy
[ __ ] crazy what's your story
he was so deep that I totally forgot my
listen man and then one time you and you
I'm in Ukraine me and my friend we go to
Ukraine right cuz we was hanging out
with some friends in Moscow and I was
totally gonna Ukraine have my friends
come pick you up because I want you but
yet by yourself me and my friend so we
get there off the private plane we get
there limos them in the limousine right
we go to this mansion this matches
impeccable
[ __ ] marble and brass and mirrors and
and and it's [ __ ] incredible hotel
and then you go up there and there's
four beautiful girls
well if you destroyed our house you say
this has to be someplace where they
could fit with the house is sold but
imagine and your data has snapchat and
20 are they've been canceled like they
have a castle they might have found some
sound somebody defecating on somebody
bestiality or why'd you bring the wine
Jesus wanted to y-yeah I just want to
tell you our man what building is your
park - I'm Nicole I'm Mike we fouled
[ __ ] we just move around yeah yeah
I'll be honest I see the pictures I see
this is an El Segundo
I see the ark every day y'all got y'all
[ __ ] put together I want to tell y'all
congratulations
so Oh Tyson can I get down with the
result I don't have a lot of money no no
was it would you like to do I would just
like to be down with y'all I just wanna
help people to bring it to the resort or
whatever
engineer music we don't drink you
normally yeah
but Tyson yes yes we got someone your
this cuz I say this plate every time I
see this two rappers right everytime I
say burn I just seen Kanye West god
bless Kanye West right god bless
somebody but why the [ __ ] would you go
see Zane Lowe god bless the table Zane
Lowe it's a guy from after music God
blessing low but you know what did Dane
low do he gives you a hundred fifty
thousand for you to sit down with him
that's a great thing and I'll get that
but at our point
what the [ __ ] do you need money for like
he made bad deals that's crazy money
but Kanye come and see the coast you
know you should have came to drink
chance she know she shoulda came to
hotboxing you know she shoulda came to
rap radar but we know you shoulda came
here believe me
do anything for him well we want to
change that narrative want to change
that he have the belief [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] how do we open up look we gonna get
Mike to drink some [ __ ] you
know he's gonna pay me a billion dollars
to drink die before a drink
okay that's all you know I seen Kanye
he's dropping the interview I don't know
when y'all and if he was dropping but
he's dropping an interview with Zane
Lowe and let me just I want to be clear
because I want to say this on someone
else's platform so it's not like I
always had taxane low I have no problem
with Zane Lowe is ain't [ __ ] low he's
a guy come on man you got I got a
professional roller here yeah I know I
know
he rolling blood stuff but um so I mean
is the music clarify I'm just clarify I
have no problem no quarrel no
discrepancy with Zane Lowe the thing is
sometimes I take offense when I see a
Kanye I see a Drake I see uh or anybody
that go with a see Zane Lowe before they
see me
mm cuz the thing about it is who is Zane
love that's that's to what you say huh
that's what you got a girl that's the
few girl I don't think it's a girl it's
a man but what I'm trying to say is it
bothers me so it's the same thing when
when a person from Earl spins to Porter
to all these guys when they announce in
a fight they should be here they should
come here and I'm just upset
understanding even if you don't want
want that Tyson I'm just saying it's
understanding if you were in a box in
everyone in boxing Oh Tyson I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't even [ __ ] Manny
Pacquiao you [ __ ] Floyd Mayweather
you're [ __ ] with Earl Spencer I don't
give a [ __ ] if you uh Anthony Wilder
I don't you [ __ ] Deontay Wilder
excuse me what happens what up whoever
you are if you're in boxing you owe ties
all right cool I'm gonna take your time
am i lying
of course I listen before we were free
we were here slaves for 400 years no 250
years right
we get the blood 20:58 right and 250 hi
we've been free from slavery 150 years
150 years yeah well if we have right
it'll take more than 150 years to stop a
slave from becoming the slave I have no
idea what's going on but I'm in yeah son
because they say it's not sleepy I don't
mean you're not slave girl right
what slaves do you do the same [ __ ] well
never stop and you was locked up in
Indiana mm-hmm I had a great time oh my
god I didn't want to leave one more time
without Mandy because when he was locked
up you called the chick from jail yeah
so she's not till this text because I
used to [ __ ] her sister was her name
like 93 I was in Deer Park where she
never she won't have Hidden Hills but
she's from Braavos as you grew up with
her no she's not for the for sale but he
was that week old
yeah but she's from on from like the
Westchester County area Oh sister I tell
you a sister named oh I know her name
bad mean
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
save oh I was so happy when like when
you started this this podcast because mm
oh girl that the nice cars out trying to
buy it off from they won't sell it to me
custom-made then no one had a band of
your own custom one you say long hey
super rich
you see I'm law like that's some real
[ __ ] right they've got a five o'clock
[ __ ] was trying to buy the car he was
trying to fight the car so we'll have
you had little last time you have a
drink you don't have people drink for 18
months don't drink like this this is
listen to some people this is a business
is [ __ ] great right here but then I
take it to the other level I think the
level is not fun no more laughing like
this because I'm back happy that could
happen that happened look like will not
drink I think I can fight when you drink
you know you let's keep you focused on
it David the worst not respect me you
say you respect me you in that respect I
don't think there's anybody that won't
respect you know I really go low oh we
don't want that yeah I don't want that
either
well Nouri men I'm so sorry did I take
no no that also
you're welcome here anytime yo please
say you got a compromise love to you
gotta come to my blog they told me you
have your next surgery I thought it was
like I thought you I was blowing me off
like no his nation will get that [ __ ]
what move but we waited this long so we
figured we didn't really want a half
step it when when you're ready we'll fly
you out to Miami
I need that re anyway cuz I seen that
Jim Jones interview I said the most you
spent 18 million why when you wanna do
that you're gonna die one day okay damn
Mike I you gave me the best advice ever
how much you gonna show off this is over
yeah when it's over you don't think it's
over do you think it's over one is over
I have no idea what's going on right
yeah that's what you are you're not
gonna exist no matter all that you did
all the [ __ ] you talk all you learned
how to write meant nothing
so we're gonna see something afterwards
no I'm asking you what do you think like
Bozo like when
that like I'm kind of like but I I
believe in purgatory I believe in heaven
I believe in hell but I don't know where
I'm going if you came back hitting that
come on I could show you where you going
say that's what we do in the toad and he
said at all plankton the toad has in its
venom this stuff called five Meo DMT did
see this yeah die let me go okay
how did you die come back yeah it's
gonna be 20 minutes but [ __ ] when you
die it's over there you go say oh [ __ ]
these [ __ ] got me what I did without
trying to prove why I'm sure and prove
to these white [ __ ] them thank
you did you do it in Joshua Tree Mexico
okay so not just retreat we gotta go to
Mexico yeah yeah cuz we gonna go to jail
if we do it here possibility that's it's
powerful man please break this down for
me so five Meo DMT you already speaking
Chinese molecule not far because I [ __ ]
about
it's a molecule I don't even know how to
describe it now after I described Molly
okay so you basically you guys for
twelve seconds and then you come back to
life and then you have no addictive at
all or did I it shows you yeah I did it
when I was on cocaine and what else I
was I'm on some other [ __ ] to twelve and
I haven't done a thing with haven't
touched anything I haven't [ __ ]
another picture nothing it unravels you
from all of your hanging all the [ __ ]
in here is like I'm not sure tricky I
know what it does what it it demands you
to be the best you could possibly be a
[ __ ] I didn't want to lose the panel
that was too hard but when I did the
thought is that you have something to do
that's the best your best and do you
still JA you still do no I still do my
two hours a day I'm gonna do a third now
I wanna do a half-hour
I used to our we're gonna get a gym in
here yeah we may better Gemma here
kitchen over there
solid partner I'll be Liza Co engineer
my soul yeah Leon yes at this stage of
my life all all of our next trial
everything dealing with our so now that
we have to stage your life what we think
you know deal with our soul so Mike
before we get about here right I'm an
egg shooter right so whatever I look at
someplace I look at make sure like do
you when you look at this room beep like
a [ __ ] everybody
like that's not how you look at like you
don't do that though by saying this
thing I can make all these [ __ ] rich
[Music]
but if party you don't say [ __ ] a by
yourself I [ __ ] myself up yeah the
active one is the [ __ ] fate of us all
we all have to be in shape handling
everybody's back you know cuz you know
if you know your convict is his life in
his life you can tuck yourself different
that's worth it mmm that's who I am
right yeah thank you think about the
people around us more than ourselves
there think about us so we have to think
about a couple of drinks and I used to
see this southern rappers and I back in
the day when they were making a lot of
money it's just one guy that looks like
the crew looks like bombs right you
couldn't even take the bus to go to
dinner you don't want dressed up you
can't take them to dinner so they'll
either and you don't know when that
looks nice maybe Elsa bum that means
you're not no leader if you're a leader
oh you got supposed to be so flat no but
she told early there is no the leader
was God great way to be man I think I
think we killed it
yeah we killed it just tell everybody
where they can find you from yeah yes
you know what in case yeah I don't have
a vault TV you don't have title or you
don't have mass appeal where everywhere
we call the drink champs you know Ari
you could buy our music anywhere
music anywhere but [ __ ] down I'm here to
promote drink chance bigger to my
partner DJ efn I Love You Man champs in
the house drink cheering big up to
Capone we love you as well
we miss you [ __ ] yes and um so just
look up three chaps anywhere man and I
want a big yeah both walk man but for
having me as soon as I figured out I was
going to LA I said ah this is the place
I got a B and take y'all man what do you
what are you coming for yes papi [ __ ]
yeah um well your puffy ass but your
votes over vote Friday Saturday and
Sunday so Saturday we have a party drink
chance party we would love if you could
come we love both your brothers come the
whole camera crew you know I'm no one's
gonna search your or anything you know
yeah good yeah what us you know same
witness stands for qbq B means queens in
the Bronx when it comes to us so you
know uh you know you come anytime you
please come you're talking she keep
talking please come and you know we are
here we New York dudes with you know we
New York dudes we love y'all to come and
hang out and our husband Rick says smoke
and smoke drinks if you're not that's
the music festival yeah I could be a job
rule bro we gotta make them look good in
this ass but what is it this is the
resort yeah the land that's here Hotel
Desert Hot Springs
you see this yeah I see this you say you
can see this is a smoke resort yeah
everything that's all this bill only for
smoking and drinking even though we
don't drink but we gotta drink twice I'm
the drink I'm gonna drink I'm the drink
across here that's what that's I'm the
hip hop oh my god you're Tyson I can't
okay yeah
Palm Springs scissor dog spray you don't
Lee after damn is dead you go to
Amsterdam - we got a couple of - we get
me to make some deal to buy a couple of
coffee shops and after them and put them
as Tyson ranches and get all those as
well we're working on that now slow baby
International is the money but [ __ ] the
money it's our legacy five hundred years
from now that's the [ __ ] I'm so happy
thanks Mel I can't believe cuz you know
what I wanted to be interviewed but
they're not so no my mother says you're
personally very family kids why yeah
yeah yeah I'm married I got a lot of
kids I don't even know how many I'm
thinking busting some more nuts my wife
because I'm married my wife I try to
tell them we get a surrogate right now
yeah let's get a little yeah cuz you
wasn't in a surrogate phase right like
no my wife's was nervous that I might
get somebody pregnant they don't you
think we have enough kids you know that
I respected her because she might have
been right so you know how many kids you
got I got seven kids eight we're lost
one back okay so let me let me just
before we end this and that wasn't
enough I don't think there was enough to
pigeons yeah where do they sleep it they
sleep in a lavish I'll show you
no I'm to my regular pitch it's not your
business we know your pizza ribbon isn't
the toss them all but I think wherever
they can
regular pizza where do they go at night
cuz I don't see the big lay the bridges
and [ __ ] and feels and tree oh it's a
good question though
that's really good question no because
you know his pigeons sleep here yeah a
lot of powers yeah they know exactly
where they going yeah but I had
nighttime pigeons just leave they're
gone and I'll be I'll be mad I feel like
I'm you see you [ __ ] on me I'm just
you being a foul demand you just leave
in that pigeon world if a pigeon [ __ ] on
you that's good luck you wanna pit in
the shin pigeon oh [ __ ]
you've been a bird bidding for five
years burn up soon your friend coming
did one day bird [ __ ] on her ha ha give
him a now he's mad and then my foot
we've mad [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you doing up here
[ __ ]
alright so how did you develop yup your
your love for pigeons how did cuz cuz
alright cool
I'm gonna 19 years old I'm out of sight
from school mean for lunch time forget
my lunch and then leave the school again
cuz these guys like picking on me
bullying me and so around yeah so when
four guys came up and they sealed me got
any money I said no and he said well I
find all I keep member that back in the
days or I find all that keeps a pack my
bags yeah they'd have my pocket in front
of money and then there's [ __ ] say yo
you want to fly with us and I didn't
know that yeah okay they said climb that
fence them [ __ ] those milk crates and
so I'm over here
so I did that and then we walk to box
they will give me going to abandoned
building but hey where you going in
there they pleaded me going to [ __ ]
bills and so when the building and give
Greg tell about the pizza so I went in
the building persuade me going there's a
bandleader so hung up then I went on a
roofer I saw a pigeon coop on some earth
and then I started selling up with the
birds but I skip school every day to go
up there that's crazy neighbors teach me
so and this is something that happen
this isn't replying you little 10 years
old wait this is my first time really
being outside without being around
people that I know these are strange
people so they failed me we going to the
jam Senna was the skate involved no the
tilton son is a center okay and people
going there to getting kids on their
down to play music and that was big but
I never did that before so I didn't know
anything about washing hygiene so I came
today one of the older brothers of the
Geiser Slurpees to get shorty meet me at
the coop tomorrow morning alright that's
[ __ ] cool the [ __ ] idea so I met him
up the coop next day and that day we
Rob's houses all day you rob houses all
day and he didn't give me much of the
money but what he did do is uh bought me
some fires [ __ ] clothes and he said
go to his next Saturday no the Sunday go
there next one and I went there in those
people didn't even remember me the
people have asked at me the week before
they didn't remember me they showed me
respect ever since then I've been in the
fight it's [ __ ] in the world mm
[ __ ] and this is mr. Haiti no no this
is like 78 77 something like that but it
was just so they broke my heart soreness
ever set my heart and broke my spirit so
bad when they laughed at me so he's
[ __ ] even known the man laughing
because he [ __ ] like oh they don't know
me but for the last minute I'm a [ __ ]
bomb and [ __ ] be cut like a [ __ ]
knife
[Laughter]
before we go yeah what's your name FN
I'm a squadron drink chance yeah yeah
yes smoke Patito big up to Boris yeah
[ __ ] that she didn't need to be on
treadmills man I'm [ __ ] drinking
makes you [ __ ] care everything oh
[ __ ] very true I go from the kind of guy
to lose 150 pounds of pounds of time I
was lucky I didn't get that bit I only
lost 70 this time look at me just wanted
to look at my whole summer vegan yeah my
sister died a little beating my mother
my whole family's like that and I just I
don't want I just don't want to follow
that legacy I wanna do that it's awesome
it's great having you guys here
I wasted you Tom great show and you know
what I respect that but please yo just
in case you know I don't first class
release right yeah of course of course
of course
no one has told you to your face because
so many people that's the problem with
our coaches so many people big you up
when you're not around I want to bring
you up to your face I'm gonna tell you
in your face how much you impacted you
know black culture hip-hop culture box
and culture period like we didn't watch
boxing before you we knew about Muhammad
Ali but when Tyson fought we knew that
it was a 12 second fight I knew we knew
we was rushing there just to see you
just knock a [ __ ] out and and
you let me tell you something it boosted
the morale every hip-hop dude here so
just in case you don't know from Tupac
[ __ ] little Aussie vert you've picked
us all up and we want to say thank you I
behalf of the whole hip-hop culture
papper all blacks and Puerto Ricans back
wall or New York I want to say that's
not it's the truth
actually the truth just really know it
all came down so I really had pride for
Brooklyn
that's real let me say something you go
anywhere in the world
there's gonna be a Brooklyn person is
off Germany and you got no way he
thought that he experienced the same
experience you experienced in your life
the same way from you know what his life
was like but Brooklyn is different Mike
oh yeah no no do you know he's all white
people there there yes my [ __ ]
building you don't get a so Austin broke
man ain't listen god bless Brooklyn it's
different my god bless Brooklyn
I thought that building I slit my
mother's welfare building now that's all
these they called humble building people
come here I got a place in Brooklyn
called Hudson Yards I think I won't get
a spot over there
Hudson yo you like that place I've only
been a double that's the only part
that's people off the roms got a player
to look up nuts and yeah there's a new
place downtown man yeah it's though but
downtown Brooklyn doesn't and it's real
close to Brooklyn it's all [ __ ] about
really what's going on dude dude man
don't move [ __ ] dr. Zee's make sure you
cool me there third base
so doctors debuted on that as well and
we saw the Luke podcast called hood
therapy herder pissed the Dutch uncle Co
therapy she that's nothing it derbies
just [ __ ] me I'm not gonna lie your
wife might not like this yes that's just
stroking her therapy man thanks for
tuning in to this episode of hot box and
check out our web site hot box in
podcast.com be sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel hot box with Mike Tyson
I'm Evan Brittany and I'm Mike
[Music]